hi I'm Matt Welch for recent TV I am
here in Las Vegas at Freedom Fest none
with Don Luskin noted fan of Paul
Krugman writer investor and author of
the new very cleverly package book I am
John Galt today's heroic innovators
building the world and the villainous
parasites destroying it welcome thank
you very much um this book has basically
nine chapters were you alternate
comparing modern figures in life two
characters from Iran's novels oh let's
go over a couple of them bill gates of
all people is Henry Rearden the mythic
concept of henry rearden is the great
innovator who devotes his life to
creating technologies that completely
transform the world and no good deed
goes unpunished he ends up getting
destroyed for the very value that he
creates and so that certainly would
happen to Bill Gates not only did he
become completely vilified by the world
that he transformed but at the height of
his powers in 1999-2000 his own nation's
government sued him as a monopoly in
other words food him because he
succeeded too much that's when Bill
Gates stepped down as CEO of Microsoft
since then the share price of microsoft
has never traded higher Bill Gates has
now gone from creating value to giving
away value so this is what happens when
the collective crushes you it's a form
of the Stockholm Syndrome he's doing
what they told them would be better
giving it away personally I wish you
keep making it Paul Krugman is Ellsworth
Toohey the I think the most interesting
character in all of rands fiction it's
Eastman Fountainhead not Atlas Shrugged
he is the scheming dwarfish newspaper
columnist who uses his position as a
newspaper columnist a tastemaker a truth
giver to undermine the heroic in all
fields and he sets as his particular
enemy Howard Roark the great creative
innovative
rebellious architect so light Krugman
who is portrayed in the book as being
physically puny sickly a guy with a born
with an inferiority complex but a great
mind and so he transforms the fury of
that inferiority complex into a take
over the world complex my view that's
what Paul Krugman is trying to do he's
using the New York Times the way in the
book else with who he used in New York
banner new york times is the newspaper
of record any lie printed there enters
the history books is truth so basically
what Paul Krugman does he just pulls out
whatever talking point is being
generated by the far left blogosphere of
hate puts it on the pages of the New
York Times and there's the history books
of truth to be cited by future scholars
as a source beyond question well
starting about nine years ago when
blogging was a brand new innovative
technology I started a project called a
Krugman Truth Squad today you would call
that crowdsourcing we got a network
several dozen bloggers we got together
and said all right every time Paul
Krugman publishes a new column we're all
just going to dissect it line by line
we're going to find every lie every
misrepresentation every inconsistency
every out of context quotation every
politicized distortion figure that out
as fast as you can email it to me I'll
stay up all night I'll package that as a
column for national review review online
we did almost a hundred of those over
six years for national review online and
it ended up in pulling Paul Krugman's
fangs as a result of that of our online
column the New York Times instituted for
the first time a corrections policy
requiring that errors whether
intentional or not made by opinion
columnist would have to be corrected
just like for a hundred years the new
york times as potent ilyas lee almost
absurdly corrected the tiniest little
air is made by its reporters but they
believe that there was no such thing as
an unfair opinion
well we made them change that policy and
ever since then fine Paul Krugman wins
the nobel prize in economics but he has
no stature anymore as a public
intellectual how is he going to
influence people when he has to tell the
truth let's close out with just talking
a little bit about Iran she seems to be
you know she what was the old Rolling
Stone cover he's hot he's sexy he's dead
I always want to do that third of our
reason but my staff will expel money out
of it what do you see her resurgence in
popularity what does it indicate what do
you how do you reflect on it honestly
the surge in popularity in Atlas
Shrugged it's been politicized
conservatives are using it to say well
of course it's popular now because
Barack Obama has created a world that's
like the collapsing world of Atlas
Shrugged where predatory government
takes over industry imposes arbitrary
regulations confiscation of wealth well
that's actually not what that was shrug
is about the main villain in Atlas
Shrugged is actually a capitalist James
Taggart the key duality in Atlas
Shrugged are the brother and sister
Dagny Taggart the good Taggart James
Taggart the bad tag they're both
businessmen what James Tiger does is for
the purposes of his own crony capitalism
he co-ops the government so what you
really have an atlas shrugged is an
unholy alliance of corrupt crony
capitalists and corrupt government now
that in that isn't a narrative that
conservatives like to tell that ought to
be a narrative the libertarians like to
tell because buck from big companies and
big government gang up who's the victim
individuals and what are we libertarians
about except individualism so that's why
and Randy's researching the book is I am
John Galt on Alaskan thank you very much
doing
you